US USE ME LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HEARING.
THIS ROOM ONE TWENTY SEVEN
CALLING FOR MEMBERS.
THIS IS THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE IN ROOM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN SERGEANTS PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
SO WELCOME EVERYONE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT A JUST A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING RULES REALLY GO
OVER.
A FIRST WE HAVE SEVEN ITEMS ON
THE AGENDA TODAY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE HEARS BILLS
AND SIGN IN ORDER.
OUR FIRST BILL THIS AFTERNOON
WILL BE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB ONE
ONE EIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO.
I WILL BE STARTING AT OPERATE IS
SUBCOMMITTEE TILL WE OBTAIN A
CORE.
FIRST OF ALL WE ARE IN
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
SO [inaudible] ONE OF I THOUGHT
YOU JUST JUMP UP.
OUT OF EXCITEMENT NO I I WAIT MY
TURN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB. ONE ONE ONE EIGHT
THE H. FROM THE CALIFORNIA ACT
AS YOUR ALL OUR WHERE THEY SURE
OF CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION
REACHING RETIREMENT AGE IS
GROWING RAPIDLY.
IN FACT THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
ESTIMATES THAT BY TWENTY THIRTY
JUST ELEVEN YEARS FROM OF ELEVEN
YEARS AWAY THE POPULATION WILL
GROW BY FOUR MILLION PEOPLE.
THIS RAPID GROWTH RATE PRESENTS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE TO
ACT TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
AGING POPULATION HAS ACCESS TO
ACCESSIBLE COMMUNITIES.
AND THE CARE AND RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED AND DESERVE DESPITE
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA'S OLDER
POPULATION IS INCREASING OUR
STATE GENERAL PLAN FAILS TO
PROMOTE THE DESIGN OF
COMMUNITIES.
THAT ALLOW THE RESIDENTS TO AGE
IN PLACE.
THAT IS WHY I AM VERY EXCITED TO
AUTHORED AB ONE ONE ONE EIGHT
WHICH WILL LAUNCH CALIFORNIA
INTO THE FUTURE AS A MEMBER OF
AARP'S AGE FRIENDLY NETWORK.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH AT THE NEXT UPDATE
OF THE STATE GENERAL PLAN
GUIDELINES TO INCLUDE THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION'S.
DOMAINS OF LIVE ABILITY.
THESE DOMAINS INCLUDE EIGHT
AREAS OF COMMUNITY LIFE THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL TO NOT ONLY SENIORS
BUT TRULY PEOPLE OF ALL AGES
THEY INCLUDE OUTDOOR SPACES IN
BUILDINGS.
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING SOCIAL
PARTICIPATION RESPECT THE SOCIAL
INCLUSION CIVIC PARTICIPATION
AND EMPLOYMENT COMMUNICATION AND
INFORMATION COMMUNITY AND HEALTH
SERVICES.
MANY CITIES ALREADY SEE THE
IMPORTANCE OF UTILIZING THE AGE
FRIENDLY NETWORK AS A PATH
FORWARD TO CITY PLANNING
INCLUDING BERKELEY SAN FRANCISCO
WEST SACRAMENTO -- HELZBERG
HERALDS BREAK LOS ANGELES ROLES
BILL SAN DIEGO IN WEST HOLLYWOOD.
SO NO MY COUNTY JUST TO NAME A
FEW JURISDICTIONS IN FACT CITIES
AND COUNTIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
ARE ALREADY PREPARING FOR THE
GROWING AGING POPULATION. TO
DATE THERE ARE THIRTY THREE
CITIES THAT HAVE JOINED THE AGE
FRIENDLY NETWORK AND ARE
CREATING COMMUNITIES THAT ALL
GENERATIONS CAN LIVE IN.
FROM THE EIGHT FROM EIGHT MONTH
OLD TO EIGHTY YEARS OLD.
BY JOINING A. R. P.'S AGE FROM
THE NETWORK ENTITIES RANGING
FROM PRIVATE PARTIES AND NON
PROFITS TO CITIES AND COUNTIES
WILL GAIN ACCESS TO A. R. P.'S
EXTENSIVE COLLECTION OF EXAMPLES.
OF BEST PRACTICES CASE STUDIES
AND POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
DEVELOPING AGE FAMILY COMMUNITY.
AND WITH ME TODAY I HAVE BOB OF
BREATH. TO FURTHER DISCUSS AGE
FRIENDLY NETWORKS AND A RETIRED
CAMP CAPTAIN OF THE NAVY AND
CHAIR OF A OUR PEACE CALIFORNIA
LIVABLE COMMUNITIES ADVISORY
TEAM.
I ALSO HAVE -- JAMES GOES ON
BEHALF OF A A RP.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER REVEAL.
UGH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR OF YOUR
CORRECT.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
ON BEHALF OF A A RP CALIFORNIA
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
MEMBERS WE THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RUBIO FOR HER LEADERSHIP AND
OFFERING A. B..
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN H. FRIENDLY
CALIFORNIA ACTIVE.
TWENTY NINETEEN WE MADE OUR
MEMBERS AWARE OF ITS POSITIVE
IMPACT AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT 87% OF ADULTS
AGE SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER WANT TO
STAY IN THE COMMUNITIES THEY
HAVE HELPED TO DEVELOP AND GROWN
TO LOVE.
AND THEY HOPE TO HAVE THE
OPTIONS AND CHOICES IN PLACE TO
DO THAT.
AT PRESENT CALIFORNIA LACKS A
STRATEGIC PLAN TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF A VERY CERTAIN DEMOGRAPHIC
CHANGE.
AB ELEVEN EIGHTEEN IS A MAJOR
STEP IN MOVING CALIFORNIA.
TOWARDS CREATING COMMUNITIES THE
WE PREPARED FOR THIS DEMOGRAPHIC
CLIMATE CHANGE WHILE CREATING A
STATE THAT IS LIVABLE FOR ALL
AGES.
SPACE SPECIFICALLY AB ELEVEN
EIGHTEEN RESONATES WITH THIRTY
THREE CALIFORNIA JURISDICTIONS
CONTAINING OVER THIRTEEN POINT
THREE MILLION CITIZENS THAT
ALREADY EMPLOY THE H. FINALLY
FRAMEWORK TO STRENGTHEN THEIR
PLANNING.
IT HARMONIZES WITH THE
OPERATIONAL CONCEPT IN THE
JOURNAL PLAN GUIDES NOW IN BUILT
ON PROGRAMS ALREADY WORKING WELL.
AND WHEN ABLE CALIFORNIA TO JOIN
THE NATIONAL A. R. P. NETWORK OF
H. FRIENDLY STATES AND
COMMUNITIES IN A STATE
GOVERNMENT CODE TO ALLOW THE
EIGHT AREAS OF LIVABILITY IN USE
BY OVER SEVEN HUNDRED CITIES
WORLDWIDE. TO BE CONSIDERED IN
THE GENERAL PLANNING PROCESS.
AS US PHILIP WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION'S GLOBAL NETWORK OF
H. FRIENDLY CITIES AND
COMMUNITIES A. R. P. PROVIDES A
LARGE VARIETY OF SUPPORTING
RESEARCH.
AND PRACTICAL RESOURCES WHEN
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND ROLE IN
THE H. FAMILY NETWORK THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS COMMIT TO
DEVELOPMENT.
OF FIVE YEAR PROCESS TO CREATE
COMMUNITIES ARE AGE FRIENDLY FOR
ALL AGES AND ABILITIES.
THEY DO THIS FIRST BY LISTENING
TO THEIR CITIZENS THEN HOLLISTER
LOOKING AT WHAT'S WORKING WHAT'S
NOT AND THEN CREATING A THREE
YEAR ACTION PLAN.
THAT ADDRESSES LABILITY I HAVE I
JUST PICKED UP CALIFORNIA AS IN
THE COUNTIES HAVE ON MY WAY UP
HERE.
OF ANYWAY ONCE WHEN THEY EXIST --
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE ONCE A
SUPPORT OF OF AN AGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA IS A REFLECTION OF
THE STATE'S EXCITEMENT
ENTHUSIASM FOR AN EVEN BETTER
FUTURE.
PROPOSALS INCLUDE UPDATING STATE
GENERAL PLAN GUIDELINES TO
SUPPORT THE WORK THAT IS ALREADY
GOING ON IN H. FRIENDLY
COMMUTERS ACROSS THE STATE.
CONSIDERATION OF THE EIGHT
DOMAINS OF A FRIENDLY FRAMEWORK
TO ENABLE THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH AND TO ENSURE THAT
APPROPRIATE STATE DATA.
ON OVERALL POPULATION IS PART OF
THE FIFTY MILLION BY TWENTY
FIFTY A PLANNING.
INFORMING JOURNAL PLAN
GUIDELINES THAT IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR ALL RESIDENTS INCLUDING THE
CONSIDERATION OF OLDER ADULTS
WHICH ARE OFTEN NOT THE WORD OF
IN THE CONCURRENT AND THE THE
CURRENT GUIDANCE.
AB ELEVEN EIGHTEEN IS A RIGHT
STEP FOR TOWARDS EMBRACE THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND FISHING
CHALLENGES OF NEW DEMOGRAPHIC
CLIMATE.
ON BEHALF OF THE RP CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
A MAN I'M SURE MEMBERS JIM GROSS
ON BEHALF THEY ARE P. VERY
QUICKLY WE ARE AWARE OF THE
CONCERNS.
RAISED BY -- CB I A I THINK THAT --
THEY HAVE -- SOME HEARTBURN
OVERREACH SOMETHING THAT COULD
TURN INTO MANDATE THIS IS NOT
INTENDED IN ANY WAY TO BE A
MANDATE THESE ARE GUIDELINES
THAT ARE VOLUNTARY THE STATUTE.
CURRENTLY SAYS THEY ARE
VOLUNTARY IT IS NOT OUR GOAL TO
IMPOSE ANY MANDATE WE SIMPLY
WANT THESE BUILT INTO THE
GUIDELINES AGO TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I THINK. THIRTY THREE
JURISDICTIONS ALREADY HAVE MOVED
IN THIS DIRECTION IS A LOSS FOR
OF THAT FACT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
REVENUE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
JOHN MICHAEL GETTING CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION --
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
SHE'S WORK WITH US AND WE'RE
GOING TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
AFTER THE SECTION WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT TAKEN OUT SO WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK AND WANT TO
WORK WITH YOU GOING FORWARD.
NOW -- JUST MENTOR DOES THE YOU
KNOW I'VE OUR THIS IS MEANT TO
BE A GUIDE LINES AND SUB BE
HAPPY TO SIT DOWN AND I WORKED
OR ANY OF THE ISSUES THAT THAT
ARE BEING RAISED AND OBVIOUSLY.
HERE -- TO SUPPORT THE AGING
POPULATION SELL -- HOPEFULLY WE
CAN COME TO A CONSENSUS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEING NONE -- LET'S SEE
DOING QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
YES.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH OF A QUESTION
BUT I REALLY WANT TO SAY THANK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS I THINK WE ALL SEE COMING
IS A SILVER TSUNAMI AND OFTEN.
I THINK MANY ELECTED OFFICIALS
AT THE LOCAL AND COUNTY AND
STATE LEVEL FEEL LIKE WHERE WE
NEED MORE GUIDANCE AND THIS IS
REALLY A BILL THAT PUTS ON THE
RIGHT PATH SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I'M I'M IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER -- COMMENTS.
A SINCE WE'VE JUST HAVE A QUORUM
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
TAKE A ROLE [inaudible]
SECRETARY AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM HERE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HERE RAM RAMOS
[inaudible]
THREE OF US THREE OF US HERE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS HERE
VOEPEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY -- WITH
THE RELIGION OR TO AN EMOTION.
I MOVE THE BILL.
HERE MOTION A SECOND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
OKAY I JUST WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AS A A PAST MEMBER OF A
SMALL TOWN IN CITY COUNCIL I
ALWAYS WANTED TO MAKE SURE OUR
SENIORS ARE TAKING CARE OF AND
WE NEED A PLAN AND IDEAS ON HOW
TO GET THERE.
AND YOU STARTED THE ROUTE FOR
MANY OF US -- AS I WILL KIND OF
QUOTE OF A DEAR FRIEND OF MINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF YOUR MOTTO
WHO IS -- IN LIVES IN DAVIS NOW
A SHE'S TO SAY WATCH OUT FOR THE
SUMMER HERE IT'S AN ARMY.
AND WE NEED TO TAKE THESE THINGS
SERIOUSLY SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY -- DIXIE ONE TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY HI LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM HI BOERNER HORVATH.
BURNER.
HI RAMOS THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
BILLS OUT.
FIVE ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WELL WE HAVE EVERYBODY HERE WE
ARE GOING TO A NOW -- DO THE
RULES THAT WE SEEM TO FORGET
LAST TIME.
SO IT UP THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY COMMITTEE RULES WHICH ARE
LOCATED THE BACK FOR YOUR
BINDERS -- I WOULD SOMEONE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR US.
HERE WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
OF THE SECRETARY.
AGUIAR-CURRY HI.
AGUIAR-CURRY I A LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH.
BURNER FOR ABOUT FIVE RAMOS
THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SITE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I'D VOEPEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RULES ARE
ADOPTED WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B. FOUR ONE ONE
MORE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE WELCOME
.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU AYE PRESENTING A
BEFORE ONE ONE WHICH =LD ALLOW
THIS CITY SANTA CRUZ TO SPEND
SOME OF THE BOND PROCEEDS THAT
WERE COLLECTED MANAGED THROUGH
THE WIND UP OF THEIR
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES CITY
SANTA CRUZ HAS BEEN A VERY GOOD
ACTOR.
NOT ONLY WITH THE WIND UP OF THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY BUT TRYING
DESPERATELY TO MEET THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEEDS IN
THEIR CITY.
THERE SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
ESSENTIALLY SITTING THERE THAT
THEY WOULD LOVE TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THEY HAVE A NUMBER OF SHOVEL
READY PROJECTS THAT ARE READY TO
GO.
BUT GIVEN THE WAY THAT THESE
AGENCIES WERE WOUND UP AND THE
LAWS THAT.
RESTRICT THE USE OF THOSE BOND
PROCEEDS WE ARE ASKING FOR
PERMISSION TO DO THAT THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
YES THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AT AGUIAR-CURRY AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
BONNIE LIPSCOMB.
I'M DIRECTOR OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY FOR THE
CITY OF SANTA CRUZ AND WITH ME
TODAY IS JOE HALL WHO'S OUR
PROJECT MANAGER AND HAS WORKED
ON THIS BILL.
BEFORE COMING FOR THEIR I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE -- FOR YOUR OF JUST
REPRESENTING IN INTRODUCING THIS
BILL FOR OUR COMMUNITY AND FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OF MY BRIEF COMMENTS TODAY WILL
TRY TO CONVEY SOME OF THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CHALLENGES
FACED BY OUR COMMUNITY OUR PAST
EFFORTS IN THE AREA OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HOW WE
MOVE FORWARD QUICKLY -- AND WILL
BE ABLE TO HAVE A BEFORE ELEVEN
IS APPROVED PRIOR TO THE
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT THE
CITY OF SANTA CRUZ CONSTRUCTED
NEARLY TWELVE HUNDRED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS THROUGH
REDEVELOPMENT.
OF WHICH THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
WERE FOR VERY LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS AND TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
ONE FOR LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
THIS IS A REALLY GREAT FROM OUR
OPINION RECORD FOR CITY OF JUST
UNDER.
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
UNFORTUNATELY THE DISSOLUTION OF
RDA IN TWENTY TWELVE LEFT A
NUMBER OF OUR CITIES PLAN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
UNABLE TO PROCEED DUE TO LACK OF
ADEQUATE FUNDING.
SINCE THEN SANTA CRUZ HAS BEEN
CITED AS ONE OF THE LEAST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MARKETS IN
THE NATION IT HAS A GROWING
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA CAMPUS.
AND IS EXPERIENCING THE
INCREASING HOW HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY PRESSURES FROM
NEARBY SILICON VALLEY.
WHAT IS ALSO UNIQUE ABOUT OUR
CITY IS THAT WE STILL HAVE
AVAILABLE STAFF AT THE CITY THAT
ARE BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DESPITE THE LACK OF
REDEVELOPMENT FUNDING WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO SINCE TWENTY TWELVE
COMPLETE TWO FOUR DOUBLE HOUSING
PROJECTS CREATING OVER SEVENTY
TWO UNITS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN OUR?
COMMUNITY BUT IT IS JUST NOT
ENOUGH WE HOPE THAT FROM A
BEFORE ELEVEN IS THAT THE
FUNDING RELEASED BY APPROVAL OF
THIS LEGISLATION WILL ALLOW US
TO MOVE FORWARD ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECT.
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE UNITS THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON WITH OUR
LOCAL TRANSIT DISTRICT IN THE
HEART OF OUR DOWNTOWN AND WITH A
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER IN
DOWNTOWN AS WELL SO WE'LL BE
ABLE TO CREATE OVER A HUNDRED A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE UNITS.
ADDITIONALLY WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE MEASURE US BOND FUNDS
ON A LIBRARY MIXED USE PROJECT
WHICH ALSO INCLUDE SUBSTANTIAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO WE HAVE TO
PROJECTS ONE VERY READY TO GO
ONE THAT WILL BE READY WITHIN
THE NEXT YEAR.NINE WILL TO BE
REALLY CRITICAL TO HELPING
SUSTAIN OUR DOWNTOWN AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR OUR
FUTURE THESE AND OTHER PROJECTS
WILL ALLOW US TO BETTER MEET OUR
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION OF WHICH WE HAVE IN
NEED OF A FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT UNITS WITHIN THE NEXT FOUR
YEAR PERIODS.
OF LOW AND VERY LOW.
SO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY AND
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT EIGHTY
FOUR ELEVEN AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
BEHALF THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SPEAK.
NO JUST TIME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE.
OKAY ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OTHERS ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE.
I LIKED IT YOU REALLY WANT.
TO QUESTION FROM ANY OF YOU.
YES.
JUST A QUICK COMMENT MY SISTER
WENT TO UC SANTA CRUZ AGO PLANT
BANANA SLUGS AND SHE ALSO WORK
FOR THE SANTA CRUZ SENTINEL SO I
KNOW HOW.
DESPERATELY YOU NEED -- THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN YOUR CITY
AND I THINK IT'S VERY ADMIRABLE
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT CREATIVE
OUT OF THE BOX WAYS TO TO REALLY
MAKE SURE YOU'RE KEEPING PEOPLE
OF ALL INCOME LEVELS IN YOUR
CITY SO I'LL BE IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS.
THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A
SECOND.
OKAY AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
HAS FOR AYE VOTE.
YOU CAN HAVE MY EYE BUT I KNOW
HOW YOU HAVE TO BE CREATIVE AND
THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX AND THAT
MANY WAS KIND OF TIED UP FOR SO
MANY YEARS.
SO MANY OF OUR CITIES ARE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT CREATIVE WAYS AND
CONGRATULATIONS I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY AND
LET'S GET THIS OUT FOR YOU.
US SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I'D LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER
HORVATH I RAMOS THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
BUT MEASURES OUT FIVE ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TRIP UP YOUR PATIENT.
OKAY -- LET'S SEE I DO NOT SEE
IS SOMEONE MEMBER BURKE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT -- THAT WILL BE ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB.
ONE ONE ZERO SIX GOOD AFTERNOON
YOUR START WHENEVER YOU'RE.
COMFORTABLE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- GOOD
AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES FIRST I'D
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT SUGGESTED IN COMMENT
FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS -- THE
ENHANCED HOMEOWNER NOTIFICATION
PROGRAM HAS BEEN SERVING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HOMEOWNERS AND
TENANTS SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE ENHANCED
PORTION OF THE PROGRAM HAS
ALLOWED THE COUNTY TO EXPAND THE
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE COUNSELING
SERVICES TENANT RELOCATION
SERVICES AND LOAN MODIFICATION
ASSISTANCE.
AS AMENDED THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
THE COUNTY TO CONTINUE TO DO THE
GOOD WORK OF THE PROGRAM FOR
ANOTHER TEN YEARS.
A WITH ME TODAY IS BRIAN STEIGER
WITH LA COUNTY THE SPONSOR OF
THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BRING STICKER REPRESENTING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND PROUD
SPONSORS OF THE SPELL WANT TO
THANK YOU OFFER FOR CARRYING
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THANK THE AYE CHAIRING YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
AMENDMENTS THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM FOR THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES BECAUSE IT HELPS
HOMEOWNERS.
AVOID FORECLOSURE AND IT ALSO
HELPS ALMOST HOMEOWNERS WE
PROTECT HOMEOWNERS FROM
FRAUDULENT -- FORECLOSURE
CONSULTANTS -- ALTHOUGH THE RATE
OF FORECLOSURE HAS SOMEWHAT
LEVEL SINCE THE HEAD OF THE
MORTGAGE CRISIS WITH THIS
PROGRAM IS IMPLEMENTED.
STILL APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED
AND FIFTY HOMEOWNERS EACH MONTH
GO TO THE FORECLOSURE PROCESS.
MOODY'S HOMEOWNERS HOMEOWNERS
ARE TARGETED BY FRAUDULENT CAN
FOR FORECLOSURE CONSULTANTS WHO
ADVERTISE SOLUTIONS IN EXCHANGE
FOR COST TO SERVICES THAT ARE
NEVER ACTUALLY RENDERED.
AB ELEVEN OH SIX WOULD EXTEND TO
TWENTY THIRTY THE PORTION OF
THIS PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS THE
COUNTY TO COLLECT A SEVEN DOLLAR
RECORDING FEE. FOUR NOTICES OF
DEFAULT AND USE OF THOSE FEES TO
PROVIDE NOTIFICATIONS TO
HOMEOWNERS ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY
OF FORECLOSURE AND THEIR RIGHTS
AS WELL AS ENABLE THE COUNTY TO
PROVIDE FREE SERVICES SUCH AS
MORTGAGE COUNSELING -- SINCE THE
COUNTIES -- INSTRUCTION THE
PROGRAM WE HAVE INVESTIGATED
ABOUT -- THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED
CASES -- AND WE HAVE BEEN ABLE.
TO PROVIDE RESTITUTION IN TERMS
OF ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS -- TO
HOMEOWNERS SIR WE WE HOPE TO GET
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY TO CONTINUE
THIS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
OTHER OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
THE LA COUNTY SHERIFF WERE IN
SUPPORT I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
GETTING OUR LETTER IN THE TIME.
OKAY I ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY I LET ANYBODY LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THE RIVER MOTION AND A SECOND --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
CERTAINLY I MEMBERS AND
COLLEAGUES I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS PROGRAM THAT
DOES ALLOW US TO CONTINUE TO
PROTECT HOMEOWNERS IN LA COUNTY
THANK YOU -- BUT IT -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS -- SMITH THANK YOU FOR
EXTENDING THIS IMPORTANT PROGRAM
FOR LA COUNTY HOMEOWNERS AND
RESIDENTS AND TAKING THE
AMENDMENT AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW US.
TO LOOK AT IT FOR A LONGER TIME
FRAME WILL BE SUPPORTING IT WITH
THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY.
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HORROR THAT
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
RAMESSIDE THREE OF US THREE OF
US I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I'VE VOEPEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB.
EIGHT NINETY ONE WELCOME AND
BEGIN WHEN IT'S CONVENIENT FOR
YOU [inaudible]
OVER HERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND YOUR MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO
BE IN BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT SOMEONE I THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THE BILL.
AB EIGHT NINETY ONE REQUIRE
CITIES AND POPULATIONS GREATER
THAN THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND AND EACH COUNTY TO
ESTABLISH A STATE PARKING
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES A PARKING
LOCATIONS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
LIVING IN THEIR VEHICLES.
CITIES AND COUNTIES WILL WORK IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES WHO WILL
IDENTIFY SURPLUS STATE PROPERTY
FOR THIS PURPOSE.
THESE LOCAL PROGRAMS WILL HAVE
FLEXIBILITY TO ESTABLISH RULES
AND REGULATIONS FOR THE PROGRAM
THAT FIT LOCAL NEEDS AS WELL AS
AN APPLICATION PROCESS THAT MAY
INCLUDE -- BACKGROUND CHECK FOR
PARTICIPANTS.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE REQUIRING
THE PROGRAM PROVIDED BATHROOM
FACILITY AND ON SITE SECURITY
FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS.
PROGRAMS CREATED UNDER THIS BILL
WILL ALSO BE ENCOURAGED TO
COORDINATE WITH LOCAL NONPROFITS
AS WELL AS CITIES AND COUNTY
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE RESOURCES
AND ACCESS TO SOCIAL SERVICES.
THAT LEAD TO LONG TERM HOUSING.
I IN THIS IN THIS JANUARY'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL GOVERNANCE AND
DISCUSS IDENTIFYING SURPLUS
STATE PROPERTY FOR HOUSING
EMERGENCY SHELTER.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE TO END HOMELESSNESS IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN MORE THAN
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE U. S.
WERE WITHOUT HOUSING AND A
QUARTER OF THOSE LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE LIVING
IN THEIR VEHICLES HAVE A SAFE
PLACE TO STAY OVERNIGHT WHILE
THEY WORK TO TRANSITION TO A
MORE PERMANENT HOUSING.
A SIX EXISTING STATE PARKING
PROGRAMS CREATED IN SANTA
BARBARA AND LOS ANGELES AMONG
OTHER AMONG OTHERS CAN SERVICE
SUCCESSFUL MODELS FOR FUTURE
PROGRAMS.
VEHICULAR HOMELESSNESS IS ON THE
RISE AND DESERVES TO BE
RECOGNIZED AND ADDRESSING
CALIFORNIA WITH ME TODAY IS PAUL
MAS YEAH WITH THE SACRAMENTO
HOMELESS ORGA ORGANIZING
COMMITTEE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
WELCOME HALL THANK YOU SO MUCH --
SO GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME IS
PAULA Là MAZIE AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SACRAMENTO
HOMES ORGANIZING COMMITTEE.
AND I'M HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINE ONE
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH SAFE
PARKING PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
SACRAMENTO WAS RANKED NINTH
AMONG THE TOP FIFTY U. S. CITIES
IN RENT GROWTH.
THERE IS A HIGH CORRELATION IN
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
INCREASES IN HOMELESSNESS. FOR
MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
HOUSING THEIR VEHICLES ARE THEIR
LAST RECOURSE THEIR LAST CHANCE
TO AVOID HAVING TO SLEEP
OUTDOORS AND PROTECTED.
EXPOSED TO THE ELEMENTS AND
OTHER DANGERS.
IT IS A PLACE THEY CAN KEEP
THEIR SURVIVAL GEAR IN THEIR
CLOTHING DRY.
SACRAMENTO'S ANTI CAMPING
ORDINANCES MAKES IT AGAINST THE
LAW. TO LIVE IN A VEHICLE AS IT
IS ALSO AGAINST THE LAW TO LIVE
OUTDOORS.
SACRAMENTO FOUND 8% OF THE
HOMELESS POPULATION WERE
SLEEPING VEHICLES ON THE POINT
IN TELLING COUNT.
ONE NINETEEN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN ON THAT SAME NIGHT IT
WAS FOUND THERE HAD BEEN 30%
INCREASE IN OVERALL.
HOMELESSNESS SINCE. 20001556%
WERE FOUND SLEEPING ON SHELTERED
WHICH WAS AN 85% INCREASE FROM.
200-015-2000 NINETEEN FOR YEARS
ARE NOT AVAILABLE YET -- BUT WE
CAN ASSUME THE NUMBERS HAVE NOT
DECREASED.
ESPECIALLY -- UNDERCOUNTED WOULD
BE THOSE LIVING IN.
THEIR VEHICLE SINCE IT'S HARD TO
DETERMINE IF SOMEONE IS SLEEPING
IN A VEHICLE IN THOSE -- LIVING
VEHICLES CAN BE SO WIDELY
DISPERSED THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY.
FOR THOSE LIVING IN VEHICLES
SINCE THEY ARE SO WIDELY
DISPERSED.
IT CAN MAKE IT HARDER TO BRING
SERVICES AND HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES TO THEM WITH SAY
PARKING PROGRAM SERVICE
PROVIDERS WILL BE ABLE TO BETTER
FORM RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEM AND
TO OFFER SERVICES -- TOO MANY IN
ONE LOCATION -- WE MUST MEET
THESE CHALLENGES OF HOMELESSNESS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES WITH CREATIVE
WAYS. TO MAKE PEOPLE'S LIVES
LESS MISERABLE.
ELIMINATING UNNECESSARY
OBSTACLES IN THEIR LIVES AND
PROVIDE A PLACE THAT IS BOTH
SAFE AND SANITARY WAS SERVICES --
I ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT AB EIGHT
NINE ONE BECAUSE IT WILL ADDRESS
MANY OF THESE ISSUES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE --
ENTERTAIN A MOTION AND SO YES
ASSEMBLYMEMBER UP SO I WANT TO
MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS -- ABOUT
THIS BILL I REALLY RESPECT YOU
FOR BRINGING AT AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE AND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH.
HERE AND AND I'M GONNA VOTE FOR
IT -- I'M -- I MADE SOME SIMILAR
COMMENTS YESTERDAY ON A BILL
THAT HAD TO DO WITH -- PROVIDING
SAFE -- PARKING OR REQUIRING CUT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO PROVIDE
SAFE PARKING AREAS.
ON ON CAMPUSES -- FIRST A COUPLE
OF A COMMENTS ABOUT THE BILL
GOING FORWARD I'M AYE I THINK --
THE LANGUAGES RIGHT NOW ON THE
CONNECTING THE SERVICES IS
ENCOURAGING -- CONNECTION TO
SERVICES IT'S AND MY VIEW
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL -- THAT ANY --
FACILITY THAT -- WORKS ON
HOMELESS ISSUES NEEDS TO
ABSOLUTELY OF HELP CONNECT TO A
TO SERVICES AND THERE'S A GOOD
WAY OF DOING THAT AND AND NOT SO
GOOD WAY OF DOING THAT SO I
THINK IT NEEDS.
TO LANGUAGE NEEDS TO BE WORKED
AND INTO THE BILL -- THE THE
OTHER -- LANGUAGE THAT I HEARD
WAS -- MERCHANTS TO SHELTER --
AND I DON'T THINK THERE'S
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT CALLS
THIS AN EMERGENCY SHELTER BUT
THIS IS DECIDEDLY NOT.
OF AN EMERGENCY SHELTER WHICH
LEADS ME TO MY LAST AND I THINK --
YOU KNOW FOR ME OF HAVING WORKED
ON THIS ISSUE FOR MANY DECADES
NOW -- ACTED IF I BECOME
DESPONDENT WHEN I THINK THAT WE
ARE -- USING PARKING LOTS TO
ALLOW -- PEOPLE SAFE PLACE -- TO
BE IN THEIR CARS OF NONE OF US
SHOULD THANK THAT A CAR IS
ANYTHING OTHER THAN SUB STANDARD
HOUSING.
AND WHEN WE OF MIKE MY CONCERN
ABOUT.
WHERE WE'RE GOING WITH WITH
THESE TWO BILLS IS THAT WERE
BEGINNING WHEN I BEGINNING WITH
ACTUALLY DONE THIS AND OTHER
CONTEXTS? TO NORMALIZE -- THE
THE IDEA THAT PEOPLE THE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD -- ALLOW
PEOPLE TO LIVE IN SUBSTANDARD
HOUSING -- AND I THINK IT SAYS
SOMETHING ABOUT WHERE WE ARE ON
ON THE ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS
RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T HAVE A GOOD ANSWER TO
WHY WE SHOULDN'T BE -- VOTING ON
A BILL LIKE THIS BUT IT JUST --
CAUSES ME TO ACHE IN MY HEART
THAT WERE ACTUALLY AT THIS POINT.
THANK YOU IN ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE OKAY SING
NONE DO WE HAVE A MOTION ALREADY
[inaudible]
WE'LL BUILD.
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE IT
WOULD -- TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLAMES COMMENTS YES OBVIOUSLY
SERVICES ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT -- AND I WOULD AGREE
WITH YOU THE FACT THAT THAT WE
EVEN HAVE TO BE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION IS THE NEEDS -- IT
SHOULD BE BENEATH US IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HOWEVER IT'S
NOT.
AND SO YES SERVICES ARE
IMPORTANT AND NO IT IS NOT AT MY
OUR GOAL TO NORMALIZE.
OF LIVING IN YOUR CAR.
HOWEVER -- AS YOU SAID RIGHT NOW
WITH THINGS THE WAY THEY ARE AND
FORTUNATELY WE DO HAVE TO TAKE
CARE OF THE CITIZENS THE BEST WE
CAN WITH WHAT WE HAVE ALLOCATED
AND I THINK THIS IS. ONE STEP
CLOSER TO FINDING A WAY TO BRING
PEOPLE TOGETHER TO FIND THEM THE
SERVICES TO BRING THEM TO
HOUSING -- AND TO MAKE THAT
TRANSITION AND I THINK RIGHT NOW
OUR RESPONSIBILITY WITH WHERE WE
ARE NOW IS TO TO TO DO THAT --
WITH THAT -- I THINK YOU THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR COMMENTS WE
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS THAT YOU PUT
BEFORE US WE APPRECIATE THEM.
THEY ARE GOOD GUIDANCE AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SO AB.
EIGHT EIGHT NINETY ONE I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL THROUGH THIS
MEASURE I KNOW IT'S A TOUGH ONE
I APPRECIATE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOMS COMMENTS
AS WELL AS YOURS AND YOUR AND
YOUR WITNESS HERE -- WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT SOMETHING RIGHT AND
ISN'T THIS IS KIND OF SAD THAT
WE ARE WHERE WE ARE BUT THE FACT
OF MATTER IS WE WANT PEOPLE SAY.
THAT'S WHAT OUR ROLE IS WE GET
ELECTED IS TO MAKE SURE THE
SAFETY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS NO
MATTER WHAT IT IS.
SO -- WE DO HAVE SOME AMENDMENTS
TO THE TIMING -- IT REFLECTED
THE ANALYSIS WILL BE ADOPTED AT
THE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTING ABOUT TODAY.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM I'D BURNER **** BATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
FROM ASIDE THREE OF US THREE OF
US I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL NOW.
RESULT SIX ONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY.
OUR NEXT WILL BE ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB TWO ONE THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RADIUS [inaudible]
YOU.
IT WILL BE.
GOING TO BE MORE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR KINDNESS AND
HELPING US OUT ON THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- WE'RE GOING TO NEXT
TIME ITEM NUMBER. FIVE AB.
NINE THIRTY ONE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RUNNER HARD ROCK.
PHASE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES
FOR HER GENEROSITY I APPRECIATE
THAT [inaudible]
SMITH WITH.
BUT THEN IT ALL THE OF OUR GREAT.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
SURE MEMBERS FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO THANK THEM AND I'M SURE ON
OUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL.
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE DISCUSSED
AND AGREED -- TO IMPRINT AB NINE
THIRTY ONE MORE REQUIRE THE
COMPOSITION OF EACH APPOINTED
STATE LOCAL.
BOARDING COMMISSION WITH AT
LEAST FIVE APPOINTED MEMBERS TO
HAVE BY 202550% WOMEN.
AT LEAST 50% WOMEN.
YOU CAN SPEAKING IF YOU'D LIKE.
OKAY I WOULD LIKE TO READ SOME
THINGS IN THE RECORD I WOULD
LIKE YOU TO READ IT THANK YOU --
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED AB
NINE THIRTY ONE WILL NOT APPLY
TO STATE BOARDS OR COMMISSIONS
WILL MAKE THE FOLLOWING CHANGES
TO SECTION THREE OF THE BILL AS
FOLLOWS.
REMOVE COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS LIMóN APPLICATION TO
CITIES WITH A POPULATION OF
FIFTY THOUSAND OR GREATER.
CLARIFY THE DEFINITION OF LOCAL
BORDER COMMISSION TO APPLY TO
ADVISORY BODIES ONLY THAT MEANS
APPOINTED BOARDS OF A ELECTED
OFFICIALS WILL BE EXCLUDED --
AND CHANGED EFFECTIVE DATE TO
TWENTY THIRTY THESE AMENDMENTS
NEAR THE BILL SIGNIFICANTLY BUT
THEY STILL GET AT THE CRUX OF
THE ISSUE WERE FIGHTING FOR
WHICH IS EQUITABLE
REPRESENTATION OF MEN AND WOMEN
ON LOCAL BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS.
THE SERVICE A PIPELINE FOR
HIGHER OFFICE.
WOMEN TO THIS DAY REMAIN VASTLY
UNDERREPRESENTED ON APPOINTED
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT. FOR
EXAMPLE FOR ME WHEN I GOT ON THE
PLANNING COMMISSION ONE OF THE
REASONS I APPLIED IT WAS IS ALL
MALE BULLARD WHO WERE DESIST
DECIDING ALL OF OUR BUILT
ENVIRONMENT.
AND THAT WASN'T OKAY -- I WAS OF
FOLLOWED BY ANOTHER WOMAN AND
NOW THERE'S AN ALL MALE BOARD
AGAIN THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WOMAN INVITED
TO THE TABLE AND AND THEY ARE NO
THEY KNOW THAT THEY ARE WELCOME
AND INVITED TO HELP BE PART OF
THE DECISION MAKING.
OF OUR CITIES.
ANOTHER COLLEAGUE ALSO SHARED
WITH ME RECENTLY THAT WHEN SHE
WAS CONSIDERING RUNNING FOR
LOCAL OFFICE SHE WAS TOLD THAT
SHE WOULD NEVER GET ON THE
PLANNING COMMISSION BECAUSE THAT
WAS THE PIPELINE TO ELECTED
OFFICE.
THESE ARE THE REAL STORIES OF
WOMEN RUNNING FOR OFFICE IN OUR
STATE AND IT'S TIME WE DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
AND IT'S AN ISSUE A STATEWIDE
CONCERN THE CALIFORNIA HAS
EQUITABLE REPRESENTATION AND WE
HAVE NARROWLY TAILORED THIS BILL
TO ADDRESS THE STORK IN EQUITIES
AND DISCRIMINATION AND
DIFFERENCE IS AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT WOMEN'S FACE.
WITHOUT FAIR REPRESENTATION LAW
WOMEN WHO ARE 52% OF THE
CALIFORNIA STRUGGLE TO SEE A
CHIEF FAIR AND EQUAL
REPRESENTATION WITHIN THE
VARIOUS BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
THAT GOVERN OUR DAILY LIVES.
DEPENDING ON THE BORDER
COMMISSION OF WHICH THEY SERVE
APPOINTEES HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS ISSUES
PERTAINING TO PERMITTING
PLANNING TRAFFIC PUBLIC SAFETY
PARKS AND RECREATION.
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY AND
STANDARDS.
THESE ARE THE NUTS AND BOLTS OF
OUR DAILY LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
AND WOMEN'S VOICES NEED TO BE
EQUITABLY HEARD.
AB NINE THIRTY ONE SIX TO REMEDY
HISTORICAL CHEN GENDER
DISPARITIES IN APPOINTMENTS TO
PUBLIC BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS BY
REQUIRING THAT LEAST HAVE 50%
WOMEN BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL JOY'S THE SUPPORT OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION OF WOMEN
AND ITS MANY LOCAL CHAPTERS.
THE STATE COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AMONG OTHER
GROUPS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
AND I HAVE HERE WITH ME TODAY SO
FOR A IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
OLGA MAC ADVOCATE AUTHOR
PROFESSOR FOUNDER OF WOMEN SIT
ON BOARDS.
MOVEMENT LEN TRITON OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
SO I'LL GIVE IT OVER TO YOU FOR
A FEW COMMON THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR TO THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE MY NAME IS OLGA
MAC I'M THE FOUNDER OF WOMEN
SERVE ON BOARDS WE HAVE
CONVINCED -- OVER FIFTEEN
FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED COMPANIES
TO DISCOVER THEIR FIRST WOMAN --
I ALSO TEACH LEADERSHIP -- TO
MEET MANY EXECUTIVES AND I ALSO
TEACH LEADERSHIP AND BERKELEY
LAW -- I HAVE WRITTEN A BOOK
ABOUT BORIS SERVICE AND I WAS
APPOINTED ON THE CALIFORNIA LAW
REVISION COMMISSION BY GOVERNOR
BROWN -- WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS -- BILL -- IT IS
WELL KNOWN THAT WOMEN ARE
REFERENCE UNDER REPRESENTED IN
MANY LEADERSHIP POSITIONS
INCLUDING GOVERNMENT POSITIONS
IN THE STATE AND THE UNITED
STATES -- AND WHILE THE PRIMARY
REASON TO SERVE ON THE BOARD OR
ANY COMMISSION IS TO PROVIDE
SERVICE AND TO MAKE GOOD
POLICIES UP WHAT WE OFTEN DON'T
UNDERESTIMATE THE BENEFITS THIS
SERVICE PROVIDES TO WOMEN.
I'LL LET ME HIGHLIGHT THE THREE
THAT I FOUND PERSONALLY VERY
IMPORTANT IN MY CAREER.
AND MY SERVICE -- ONE IT
PROVIDES VISIBILITY -- MOST OF
SERVICES IS PUBLIC IT IS
RECORDED IT IS AVAILABLE FOR
PEOPLE TO ATTEND.
THAT HIGHLIGHTS THE SKILLS AND
VIEWS AND CREDIBILITY FOR WOMEN
CLOSER.
A NUMBER TWO IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN MOST
LEADERSHIP SKILLS AND
SUBSTANTIVE SKILLS SO WHEN YOU
SEE IT AT A GOVERNING BODY YOU
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY IT DAY TO
DAY JOB MAY OR MAY NOT PROVIDE
YOU WITH LEADERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES ARE OPPORTUNITIES
TO MANAGE BUDGETS WHICH A
CRITICAL FOR WOMEN TO ADVANCE.
AND MANY BODIES LIKE THIS FOR
EXAMPLE DEAL WAS CUTTING EDGE
ISSUES AGAIN THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
BE AN OPPORTUNITY IN YOUR DAILY
JOB.
NUMBER -- THREE WE HOLD OUR
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS TO VERY
HIGH ETHICS AND STANDARDS.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT EVERY
LEADER CAN BENEFIT FROM --
SERVING ON THE GOVERNMENT BODY
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROVE
YOURSELF AS AN ETHICAL AND
LEADER OF A GREAT INTEGRITY --
THERE NUMEROUS STUDIES HOW LONG
IT'LL TAKE US TO REACH PARITY IN
VARIOUS LEADERSHIP.
YES IN THE IN THE UNITED STATES.
ARE FOR EXAMPLE ON CORPORATE
BOARDS IT WILL TAKE FORTY TO ONE
HUNDRED YEARS SO LET ME PUT INTO
PERSPECTIVE IN FORTY YEARS I
WILL BE ABOUT.
EIGHTY AND IN ONE HUNDRED I WILL
BE.
ONE FORTY SO THAT IS TO SAY THIS
WILL NOT HAPPEN IN MY LIFETIME.
LET ME GIVE YOU ANOTHER
PERSPECTIVE I HAVE AN EIGHT AND
TEN YEAR OLD TWO DAUGHTERS.
IN FORTY YEARS THEY'LL BE ALMOST.
FIFTY AN IN THE HUNDRED YEARS SO
BE A HUNDRED AND TEN THAT MAY
NOT HAPPEN IN THEIR LIFETIME.
SO I SAY THAT ONE LIFETIME IS A
LITTLE TOO MUCH TO WASTE AND TWO
IS DEFINITELY TOO MUCH.
THE OPPORTUNITY HERE FOR US --
WE ARE.
IN THE HISTORIC TREND TO TOWARD
GENDER PARITY THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE IS TO ACHIEVE IT IN OUR
LIFETIME AND THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE IS FOR CALIFORNIA TO BE A
LEADER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
IN THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS PLAN
TRENTON REPRESENTING CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA.
WE WENT TO COMMAND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURNER HARD FOR ITS FOR
BRINGING THIS ISSUE TO ATTENTION.
I IT'S FITTING THAT THIS BILL
FOLLOWS ON THE HEELS OF EQUAL
PAY DAY.
WITHOUT EQUAL REPRESENTATION WE
CANNOT HAVE A QUALITY.
AB NINE THIRTY ONE TAKES THE
FIGHT TO THE GRASS ROOTS BY
REQUIRING EQUAL REPRESENTATION
ON LOCAL COMMISSIONS AND
REQUIRES REPORTING. TO IDENTIFY
CONTINUE IN AN EQUITIES AND
BOARD APPOINTMENTS.
A COUPLE OF STATISTICS ON THE
DIFFERENCE WOMEN IN LEADERSHIP
MAKE.
RESEARCH ON LOCAL COUNCILS IN
INDIA DISCOVERED THAT THE NUMBER
OF DRINKING WATER PROJECTS IN
AREAS WITH WOMEN LEAD COUNSELS
WITH 62% HIGHER THAN THOSE WITH
MEN LED COUNCILS.
IN NORWAY.
A CAUSAL RELATIONSHIP WAS FOUND
BETWEEN THE PRESENCE OF WOMEN ON
COUNCILS.
AND COMMISSIONS -- AND INCREASED
CHILD CARE COVERAGE.
AND WE KNOW THE BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS PROVIDE ADVANTAGES
SUCH AS PROVIDING AN IN DEPTH
EXAMINATION OF ISSUES OR A
COMMUNICATION CHANNEL WITH
LECTER OFFICIALS.
AND THE COMMUNITY AND BRING IN A
BROAD RANGE OF IDEAS AND
EXPERTISE EXPERTISE TO PUBLIC
DECISION MAKING.
AND FINALLY ASSISTING IN THE
RESOLUTION OF CONFLICTS AND
PROVIDING TRAINING FOR NEW
LEADERS.
WHAT BETTER PLACE FOR A WOMAN'S
VOICE TO BE HEARD? FOR THESE
REASONS CONSUMER ATTORNEYS IS
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BELL AND
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS TING
HUTCHINGS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES -- THAT WE DO
NOT FORMALLY WEIGH IN ON THE
MEASURE -- PRIOR TO THE
COMMITTEE AND ALICE SAYS IN FACT
ARE -- YOU'RE HAVING A REVIEW
BUYER ARE.
LEAKS INTERNAL DIVERSITY CAUCUS
OR WHEN IT'S CAUCUS TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS MEASURE TO SEE HOW
WE CAN FIND WAYS TO MAKE IT
IMPROVED BUT WERE GIVEN -- I WAS
GIVEN ABOUT A IT'S A TWO HOUR
NOTICE -- FROM A THIRD PARTY
THAT THE BILL WAS BEING AMENDED
TO SPECIFICALLY TARGET CITIES --
WHICH IS WHERE WHICH IS WHY I
HAD TO COME IN AND JUMP IN AND
AND AND SHARE SOME CONCERNS WE
HAVE THE MEASURE I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFFER VERY
THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF THE MEASURE
I YOU KNOW BEST I CAN TELL.
I'VE ACTUALLY SEEN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE GOING TO BE --
PUT IN THE MEASURE -- BUT
HEARING THE BREAKDOWN OF THE
MEASURE IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT THE
ONLY.
OUT FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE THAT WAS
ACTUALLY ADDRESSED INDIA
MADMAN'S WAS SIMPLY THE
DEFINITION OF A LOCAL BOARD AND
COMMISSION AND SO NOW E ARE.
CREATING A A BIFURCATED SYSTEM --
FOR FOR CITIES -- IN GIVEN THAT
IT'S A MATTER STATEWIDE CONCERN
IT APPLIES TO CHARTER CITIES AS
WELL -- BUT COUNTY SPECIAL
DISTRICTS IN THE LIKE --
CONTINUE TO GO ON BUSINESS AS
USUAL WITH DESPITE THE FACT THAT
I HAVE NOT YET SEEN ANY SORT OF
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC DATA THAT IS
THAT THAT.
LEADS.
ANYONE TO BELIEVE IN ME TO
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A MORE OF
AN ISSUE WITH CITIES VERSUS
OTHER FORMS OF THAT STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT -- WITH THAT WE
WE KNOW WE WOULD ASK THAT WE
WOULD YOU KNOW I TOTALLY GET
UNDERSTAND I THINK OUR MEMBERS
GET UNDERSTAND WHERE -- THE
MEMBER WOULD LIKE TO GO IN AND
HAS HAS CERTAINLY ARE --
ARTICULATED AYE AYE CHALLENGE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL -- I DO SEE IT
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
COULD WORK ON COLLABORATIVELY
SHOULD WE BE -- INCLUDE ON THE
FRONT END TO WORK ON BIG MAYBE
BEST PRACTICES OUR GUIDANCE IS
AND HOW WE CAN APPOINT -- AND
NOT JUST -- WOMEN AND OTHER
OTHER FORMS OTHER.
UNDER REPRESENTED GROUPS AS AS
WAS ARTICULATED IN THE ANALYSIS --
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT COMPLIANCE
ISSUES THAT WE WE FEEL THAT
WOULD WOULD BE VERY CHALLENGING
AND UNDER THIS MEASURE -- I
UNDERSTAND THAT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THE BILL WILL LIKELY
MOVE TODAY BUT WOULD WOULD ASK
THAT -- PERHAPS THIS COMMITTEE
TAKE PAUSE AND AND UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS NOW CREATES A
BIFURCATED SYSTEM BY WHERE
CITIES ARE BEING -- FORCED TO
COMPLY WITH A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND
MANDATES -- WHEREAS OTHER.
AGENCIES ARE NOT -- WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY A OPPOSED TO POST
MEASURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE IS
OR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OTHER A QUESTIONS OF
THE CODE -- YES THIS BILL SORRY
THIS VERY -- CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE DEAL GIVENS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION -- WITH WITH A
MEMBERS HAS PROPOSED WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS LEFT WITH THE BILL.
THE AUTHORS WORK ON THIS YOUR
STAFF AND THE ANALYSIS -- BY THE
COMMITTEE THEY WERE MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN HEARST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA THE
ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND FOR MY COLLEAGUES
AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
WITH THE AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY
THE AUTHOR AND ASSISTED BY THE
STAFF AT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE WILL BE REMOVING
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY COMBAT QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
YES.
THE STAFF.
MEMBERS [inaudible]
PREVIOUS [inaudible]
COMMENT -- I JUST WANNA THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- BURNER ****
BATH FOR OF PRESENTING THIS BILL --
YOU KNOW IN LOS ANGELES UNDER --
MAYOR GARCETTI'S LEADERSHIP --
FOR THE FIRST TIME WHEN HE TOOK
OFFICE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN OVER
50% OF HIS APPOINTED
COMMISSIONERS WERE WOMEN -- I
KNOW HE'S VERY PROUD OF THAT I
WAS APPOINTED TO A COMMISSION
PRIOR. TO SERVING HERE -- AND IN
UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP TO FOR THE
FIRST TIME THERE WERE NO ALL
MALE -- COMMISSIONS IN THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES AND IT'S
SOMETHING MY CITY IS VERY PROUD
OF AND CELEBRATE ST -- I'M GLAD
THAT YOU'RE BRINGING THIS FOR TO
ALL CITIES THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER UNLOCKING
YEAH.
I'D LIKE TO JUST SAY THANK YOU.
FOR OUR MEETING YESTERDAY YOU
CAME INTO MY OFFICE AND WE
DISCUSSED THIS.
A LITTLE BIT AND I WHOLE
HEARTEDLY APPRECIATE THE INTENT
OF THIS BILL.
BUT I HAVE A COMMENT ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION I LIKE YOU TO
CONSIDER.
A 50% OF A FIVE MEMBER BOARD IS
TWO AND A HALF WOMEN.
AND YOU CAN'T HAVE TWO AND A
HALF PEOPLE OBVIOUSLY.
THAT BEING SAID ON THE SAME FIVE
MEMBER BOARD.
MEMBER WOULD NOW MAKE UP.
THREE OF THE TOTAL NUMBERS WHICH
MANDATES MAJORITY AND NOT EQUAL
REPRESENTATION.
WE CAN AGREE THAT DIVERSITY
ACTUALLY BRINGS ABOUT DIFFERENT
IDEAS.
BUT I BELIEVE THE APPLICATION OF
THE PERSON 50% ROLE AS
PROBLEMATIC.
I WOULD PROPOSE THAT WHEN THE
BOARD IS COMPRISED OF FIVE
MEMBERS.
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD MANDATE
AT LEAST TO BE WOMEN.
SIMILARLY WHEN THE BOARD HAS.
SEVEN THREE SHOULD BE WOMEN WITH
NINE MEMBERS.
AND FOR SHOULD BE WOMEN AND SO
ON THIS DOESN'T RESTRICT OTHER
WOMEN FROM BEING APPOINTED TO
THE BOARD.
IT SIMPLY SHOWS THAT A GROUP
TYPICALLY NOT REPRESENTED.
HAS A WELCOME SEAT AT THE TABLE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE TWO WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE DO HAVE MOTION SECOND OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS -- I KNOW THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR MANY OF
US WOMEN MAKE UP A MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS -- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I FIRMLY
AGREE WE NEED MORE WOMEN ON
ADVISORY BOARD SELECTIVE OFFICE
IN IN ALL AREAS OF GOVERNMENT.
AS THE FIRST WOMAN ELECTED AS
THE MAYOR CITY OF WINTERS I
UNDERSTAND ALL TOO WELL ALL THE
CHALLENGES OF GETTING WOMEN INTO
OFFICE AND KEEPING US THERE.
WE HAVE HAD EXTENSIVE DISCUSSION
THE TWO OF US ABOUT THE CONCERNS
I HAVE ABOUT YOUR BILL I WANT TO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SPENDING
SOMETIME PROPOSING SEVERAL
AMENDMENTS. TO NARROW THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL A TO DRESS SOME OF
MY CONCERNS ABOUT THE IMPACT ON
RURAL COMMUNITIES.
I REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT A FEW
THINGS BUT I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THOSE ALL.
IRONED OUT -- I AM A SO I
SUPPORT YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE THE
COMMITMENTS ON THE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS TO GO TO THE
ACCOUNTABILITY ADMINISTRATIVE
REVIEW COMMITTEE.
AND I WILL BE VOTING YES FOR
YOUR BILL TODAY.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH I
BOERNER HORVATH BYE RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS FIVE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL HI [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO IS THIS
YOUR FIRST BILL IT IS MY FIRST.
IT'S ALWAYS IMPORTANT TO
CELEBRATE THE FIRST BILL
[inaudible]
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE NOW ON ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB TWO ONE THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH.
YOU HAVE A GROUP OF HERE NOW.
ONE OF THEM YEAH.
YOU WERE GOING MIDDLE YEAH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE WERE
TRYING TO GET.
EVEN ONE MORE CHAIR BUT WE'RE
GONNA TAKE TURNS WITH ONE OF OUR
WITNESSES.
IT WON'T TAKE LONG.
I WANT TO START OFF BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF. FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE PUT
INTO THIS BILL.
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUE.
AND NEWLY ADDED JOINT AUTHORED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH I PRESENT
TO YOU AB.
TWO THIRTEEN AB TWO THIRTEEN IS
A MEASURE BUILT ON FAIRNESS AND
EQUITY.
AVENUES THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
ALLOCATED TO CITIES AT ANNEXED
INHABITED TERRITORIES.
WERE TAKEN AWAY IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN DURING CALIFORNIA'S
RECESSION.
HISTORICALLY VEHICLE LICENSE
FEES DISTRIBUTED OR DISTRIBUTED
TO CITIES.
THAT INCLUDED ANNEXED AREAS.
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN SB EIGHTY
NINE WAS PASSED BECAUSE OF STATE
BUDGET SHORTFALLS.
THIS LEGISLATION IN A FACT TOOK
AWAY TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
ANNUALLY IN VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
REVENUES FROM CITIES ACROSS THE
STATE.
MANY OF THE CITIES WERE AFFECTED.
MANY OF THE CITY'S AFFECTED WERE
NEWLY INCORPORATED AREAS AND
CITIES THAT HAD ANNEXED NEW
TERRITORIES.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LOST HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
REVENUES.
OVER ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
ANNEXED CITIES LOST REVENUE
DURING THIS LEGISLATIVE PERIOD.
INCLUDING THE CITIES OF FONTANA
IN MY DISTRICT SENATE CLARITY
CLARISSA IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH'S DISTRICT.
AND CHICO AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER'S DISTRICT. FOR
ANNEXING CITIES MANY OF WHICH
ARE CURRENTLY CASH STRAPPED THE
LOSS OF THIS CRITICAL SOURCE OF
FUNDING HURTS THEIR RESIDENTS.
CITIES PUTTING THESE BECAUSE IN
THIS POSITION OFTEN WAS CUT
CRITICAL SERVICES SUCH AS
INVESTING IN LOCAL.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PUBLIC SAFETY
IN ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE FOR WHAT
MANY CONSIDER TO BE AN
INCOMPLETE BUDGET.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION IS BILLY GREEN
CHIEF OF POLICE FOR THE CITY OF
FONTANA.
AS WELL AS COUNCIL MEMBER BOB
KELLER FROM THE CITY OF SANTA
CLARITA AND RANDALL STONE MAYOR
OF CHICO.
BUT FIRST I'D LIKE TO MY JOINT
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH TO
PRESENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND AND A THANK YOU BIG THANK
YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN RAY AS FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION I AM REALLY PLEASED
TO BE ADDING ON AS A JOINT
AUTHOR ON THIS MEASURE.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
EXCELLENT HISTORY ON THE VLF AND
HOW THE VARIOUS FIXES OVERTIME
IN BACK FEELS HAVE IMPACTED
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
WHEN SB EIGHTY NINE WAS PASSED
AS PART OF THE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN BUDGET CITIES IN MY
DISTRICT BECAME THE LOSERS AS
THE ANALYSIS INDICATES?
I SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
FIXES THE FORMULA GOING FORWARD
INSTEAD OF BACK FILLING LOSSES.
HAVING THIS KIND OF FUNDING
STABILITY WILL ALLOW CITIES A
BETTER FOUNDATION TO HELP PLAN
FOR RESILIENT BUDGETS -- AGAIN I
I AM JUST MORE THAN PLEASED TO
BE A JOINT AUTHORED THIS BILL
AND I APPRECIATE OUR WITNESSES
AND IT'S IN SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU.
BUT FOR LIKE TO SPEAK.
YOU CAN SPEAK UP.
NOR THE STE OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SURE I A
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR A ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY --
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT THAT OUR
MAYOR IS ALSO IN ATTENDANCE --
IT TO IN SUPPORT OF THIS I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THINK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
I AND I JUST WANNA TAKE QUICK
SECONDS TELL YOU WHAT IT MEANT
TO THE CITY OF FONTANA.
WELL WHEN WE LOST THIS MONEY IN --
TWENTY ELEVEN IT'S NOT A
COINCIDENCE THAT WE ALSO LOST
OUR SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICER
PROGRAM -- WE TOOK COPS AT A
KIDSOUT OF SCHOOLS WITH KIDS
AND WE ALL UNDERSTAND HOW
IMPORTANT THAT RELATIONSHIP IS
IN CONTROL IN THOSE FIRST
CONTACTS AND AND BUILDING A
SOLID RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE THE
YOUTH THAT BECOME THE ADULTS OF
OUR COMMUNITY -- AND WE LOST A A
MEASURE IN BEING ABLE TO DO THAT
WHEN WE LOST THIS MONEY -- WE
UNKNOWINGLY.
EXACERBATED THE IMPACT OF THE
THE LOSS OF THIS REVENUE -- WHEN
WE PURCHASED BODY MORE CAMERAS
AND THEN -- THIS YEAR -- WITH
THE PASSAGE OF FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE WE'RE PULLING MORE COPS OFF
THE STREET BECAUSE OF THESE
UNFUNDED MANDATES WE'VE WE'VE
BEEN DOUBLE DOWN ON THE IMPACT
AND THE HIT TO US.
OF WHAT HAPPENS IN JULY WITH THE
NEW LEGISLATION WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE IMPACTS OF THAT OUR BUT
WE'RE WE'RE PULLING MORE COPS
OFF THE STREET -- WE LOST
FUNDING OF TEH WE HAD TO TAKE
OUR COPS OUT OF SCHOOLS WERE
POORLY COPS OFF THE STREETS OUT
OF COMMUNITY MEETINGS AND
CINNAMON OFFICE IN OFFICES -- TO
READ ACT TO LEARN TO WORK VIDEO
EQUIPMENT BEFORE THAT WE WE
NEVER HAD TO WORK -- BUT WE'RE
WE'RE HURTING IN TERMS OF GATE
KEEPING OUR GUYS OUT THERE ON
THE AND GALS OUT THERE ON THE
STREET.
IT WILL GO A LONG WAY TO HELP US
SO IT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE -- FOR CURRY
AND OUR VICE CHAIR HOME LACKEY.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AM COUNCIL MEMBER BOB KILLER
FROM THE CITY OF SANTA KOREA AND
I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SANTA CRUZ CITY COUNCIL. TO
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL.
TWO THIRTEEN THE CITY OF SANTA
THERESA HAS MADE A TOP PRIORITY
TO ENSURE THAT ANNEXATIONS BY
THE CITY OR FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE.
AND MAINTAIN THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR ALL OF OUR RESIDENTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTEEN WILL
HELP RESTORE THE REVENUE ARE
CITY RELIED UPON.
WHEN MAKING THE POLICY ISSUE TO
ANNEX AND SERVE NEW RESIDENTS?
THE CITY OF SANTA CREDO HAS
ANNEXED MANY INHABITED
COMMUNITIES TO IMPROVE SERVICES
AND BETTER FACILITIES FOR THE
NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF SENATE BILL
EIGHTY NINE CHAPTER THIRTY FIVE
STATUTES OF TO WILL LET OUR
TWENTY ELEVEN THE CITY HAS LOST
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN VEHICLE LICENSE FEE REVENUES
ANNUALLY.
THE LOSS OF VEHICLE LICENSE FEES
REVENUES HAVE REQUIRED THE CITY
TO REALLOCATE RESOURCES.
FROM OTHER PROGRAMS TO FUND THE
MAINTENANCE FOR NEWLY ANNEXED
AREAS.
AS A CITY CONSIDERS FUTURE
ANNEXATIONS ON A LONG TERM
MAINTENANCE OF THESE AREAS.
IT IS CRITICAL.
THE VEHICLE LICENSE FEEREVENUES
BE RESTORED TO THE CITY'S.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTEEN WILL
APPROPRIATELY RESTORE THE AND
SENDING FOR CITIES TO ANNEX
INHABITED AREAS.
IN AN ULTIMATE EFFORT TO IMPROVE
SERVICE DELIVERY AND MAINTENANCE
OF ADEQUATE INFRASTRUCTURE
WITHIN THEIR RESPECTIVE
COMMUNITIES [inaudible]
ADDITIONALLY.
THIS BILL WILL MAKE FUTURE
ANNEXATIONS FISCALLY VIABLE AND
ALLOW FOR LOCAL AGENCIES TO
CONSOLIDATE AND IMPROVE SERVICES
AND DELIVERY. TO RESIDENCES
THROUGHOUT THIS GREAT STATE.
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF THE
CITY COUNCIL OF SANTA CREDO I
URGE YOUR YES VOTE ON ASSEMBLY
BILL.
TWO THIRTEEN AND I APPRECIATE
VERY MUCH YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION FOR THIS IMPORTANT
MATTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO IT --
WELCOME MAYOR STONE FROM CHICO
NICE TO SEE YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIR AGUIAR-CURRY AND AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU -- TO TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES FOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- YEAH
THIS IS A PERENNIAL PROBLEM --
WE'VE HAD IN THE CITY OF CHICO --
WE NEED TO ROLL BACK OUR SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICERS AT WHEN DOING
THIS MONEY WASN'T COMING TO US --
TO TUNE FOR HER AND SEVEN ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ARE BUDGETS FOR THE PAST FIFTEEN
YEARS OR SO OR LONGER HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY STRAINED -- AND A
TWENTY THIRTEEN WE SET OUT JUST
AT THE TIME THAT WE WERE FEELING
THIS IMPACT WE SET OUT -- TO TO
FIX OUR OUR BUDGET CONSTRAINTS.
AND THEN OF COURSE AS OF LATE
WE'VE BEEN HIT WITH A CAMPFIRE
WE ARE THE BASE CAMP. FOR FOR
THE CAMP FIRES -- RESTORATION
AND AND THEIR RESILIENCE ACOSTA
CONSEQUENTLY THAT FOR HER AND
SEVEN ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOES A LONG WAY THAT'S THREE
POLICE OFFICERS THAT CERTAINLY --
SKILLED SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS
AND AS WE'RE TRYING TO RETOOL --
POST DISASTER WE NEED ALL THE
HELP THAT WE CAN GET -- I'VE I
BROUGHT MY ASSISTANT CITY
MANAGER AND FINANCE DIRECTORS --
HERE AS WELL -- TO SUPPORT
RACISM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MERE APNE AT A WAR FROM THE
GREAT CITY OF FONTANA.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHORS OF
THIS GREAT DEAL WE ARE IN SUCH
SUPPORT OF THIS NEED WE LOST SIX
OFFICERS.
AND WE ARE VERY PROSPEROUS IS
ALREADY BEEN DICTATED THAT
FONTANA'S THE MOST PROSPEROUS
CITY.
SO THANK YOU FOR THIS
CONSIDERATION YOU WILL MAKE A
HUGE IMPACT TO OUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR MY NEW
NAME IN.
I'M CHAIR MEMBERS CHASING AND
SALAS REPRESENT THE CITY'S A
CAMERI -- PALMDALE THOUSAND OAKS
ROSE BILL IN THE PROSPEROUS CITY
OF FONTANA AS WELL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MAX PERRY THE CITY OF RIVERSIDE
AWESOME SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
A TANK YOU'RE GONNA BE AWFULLY
CALIFORNIA CITIES THERE'S ALSO
FORTY ONE CITIES LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL -- I'M ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
ON BEHALF OF CAL LAUGHED CO TWO
TO COMMUNICATE THEIR SUPPORT --
THIS THIS IS SOMETHING THAT ON
ALWAYS ABOUT FIXING A WRITING A
WRONG BUT ALSO ABOUT REESE
RESTORING THE POLICY GOING
FORWARD THAT THAT HAS A LOT OF
IMPLICATIONS ON THE STREET
STATES GROWTH PATTERN SO
PREACHERS SUPPORT.
KERR BLACKBURN HERE ON BEHALF OF
CITIES UP TO MACULA EN EL CENTRO
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE ROSSA BEHALF
OF THE MARIN COUNTY COUNCIL
MAYORS AND COUNCIL MEMBERS IN
SUPPORT.
CHRIS CONSTANTINE ASSISTANT CITY
MANAGER CITY OF CHICO WHEN I
CAME IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN WE
WERE NEAR BANKRUPTCY.
WE TURN THAT AROUND WE'RE NOW
SLATED TO TAKE SOME WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COUNTY THE
MOST -- SOCIO ECONOMICALLY LOW
REVENUE AND NEGATIVE REVENUE
GENERATING ANNEXED AREAS IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND AS A RESULT THE
COUNTY TOOK AWAY THEIR FIRE
STATION SO WE'RE PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL SERVICES.
ADD TO THAT THAT WERE ONE THE
ONLY CITY IN THE NORTH STATE
THAT IS A HIGH RISK CITY AS
IDENTIFIED BY THE STATE HONOR
YOU COULD IMAGINE.
NOW DUMP THE CAMPFIRE WE CAN'T
DO WITHOUT THIS FUNDING -- SO WE
APPRECIATED AND WE ARE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THE QUICK COMMITTEE TODAY.
A HUG.
GO.
SOME A ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
SOME OF THEM -- MOTION AND A
SECOND -- WE'VE GOT AN AREA
SORRY I GUESS I SHOULD PAY
ATTENTION.
TO I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THINK IN SUPPORT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY THE
HUNDRED AND FORTY CITIES.
THAT ARE AFFECTED INCLUDING OUR
TO SEE OUR CITIES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVALS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IKE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BECAUSE I I COMMEND BOTH
YOU FOR PUSHING THIS FORD. TO
RESTORE PROPERTY TAX DOLLARS TO
CITIES THAT SEEK TO EXPAND I
SUPPORT MAKING OUR CITIES HOLE
OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
CONTINUE TO GROW THANK YOU FOR
BRING IT FORWARD YOU'RE MAKING A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAPPY TODAY.
SEC TABLE TO CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM BLOOM I BOERNER
HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS
[inaudible]
RAMESSIDE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIGH ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I EIGHT ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS.
ALL RIGHT NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB SIX THIRTY ONE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY I BELIEVE
I SAW YOU HERE
.
DO I NEED
TO GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY WELCOME THANK YOU
TO START.
WAITING OUTSIDE IS ISN'T COZY
CON BY IN A COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE RELATES TO MY
DISTRICT.
AGAINST THE DISTRICT BILL LATE
TO MY TRANSIT DISTRICT
SACRAMENTO R. T. HELPING THEM
EXPANDED PROVIDE BETTER SERVICES
IN THE SACRAMENTO REGION.
SPECIFICALLY AS A NUANCED ISSUE
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
LEGISLATURE ALLOWING THEM TO
LOWER THE THRESHOLD FOR CITIES
TO LEAVE THE TRANSIT DISTRICT.
BY A BOARD VOTE FROM 80% 267%
HIS SENSITIVE CUP ON NEW CITIES
THAT WANT TO PARTICIPATE.
WITH OUR TEAM BUT THERE ARE A
LITTLE BIT LEERY ABOUT THIS BILL
THRESHOLDS THIS WILL.
CREATE A BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY
EASIER PATH FOR SOMEBODY CITIES
TO WORK WITH OUR TEA AND EXPAND
TRANSIT IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AGAIN SATURDAY AS A PRIMARY
PROVIDER PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION PASSENGERS
RIDE IN OUR LIGHT RAIL AND BUS
ROUTES ANNUALLY.
AND WOULD ASK YOUR I. BUT TODAY
WITH ME AS MARC WATTS WAS SACKED
OUR T. GOOD AFTERNOON MR WHAT'S.
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON --
CHAIR MEMBERS.
HOUSE THIS PASSAGE OF THIS BILL
WILLALLOW OUR T. TO HONOR THE
COMMITMENT MADE TO THE TWO MOST
RECENT -- CITIES ARE ANNEXING.
INTO OUR SYSTEM.
THEY FELT IT WOULD BE MORE --
ATTRACTIVE IF THEY HAD A LITTLE
BIT LESS OF A THRESHOLD AND
THAT'S THE BASIS FOR THE BILL SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO CITIES BY
THE WHERE.
CITRUS HEIGHTS IN ELK GROVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
I GUESS IS QUITE A YEAR LOCAL.
YEAH THE WIND ENTERTAINING.
MOTION.
WITH THE BILL.
WE HAVE A SECOND OKAY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
SB RIVAL THANK YOU -- I WILL BE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY I
KNOW HOW IT IS WHEN YOU START
ADDING YOU CITIES OF ANY TO MAKE
SURE YOUR VOTE DOWN SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRING IT FORTH
GOOD LUCK -- SECRETARY TAKE THE
ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKEY.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
FROM ASIDE THREE OF US THREE OF
US I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS SIDE VOEPEL.
MEASURES AT SIX ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MAKE
YOU.
OKAY NOW WE WILL DO ADD ONS
[inaudible]
SECRETARY
.
I AM.
TOO ITEM TO AB.
FOR ELEVEN MARKS AT MIT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARK STONE.
LACKEY RAMOS.
RAMOS SIGH [inaudible]
LACKEY.
AN ITEM.
TO AB FOR ELEVEN MARK STONE
[inaudible]
LACKEY I HOTEL.
AND GOT AND OKAY [inaudible]
ITEM. THREE AB SIX THIRTY WHEN
MCCARTY.
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE VOEPEL.
A ITEM FOR AB EIGHT NINETY ONE
BURKE LACKEY.
LACKEY I ITEM SIX A. B. ELEVEN
OH SIX MAP LACKEY.
LACKEY I VOEPEL.
ITEM SEVEN AB ELEVEN EIGHTEEN
BLANCA RUBIO.
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE RAMOS.
RAMOS FIVE VOEPEL [inaudible]
I ITEM THIS ITEM.
SEVEN AB [inaudible]
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN VOEPEL I I AM
TOO AB FOR ELEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARK STONE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL I ITEMS THREE AB SIX
THIRTY WHEN MCCARTY VOEPEL.
WHICH ONE ITEMS THREE BY
[inaudible]
VOEPEL HI.
IT IS.
AN ITEM SIX A. B. ELEVEN OH SIX
MEN VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL HI [inaudible]
MEETING DURING [inaudible]
JOURNAL OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN
GERMANY